[Musik]
weihnachten steht vor der tür und
millionen deutsche fragen sich warum
muss ich meine familie bei vollem
bewusstsein ertragen muss man nicht
[Musik]
natürlich gibt es die christlichen
klassiker alkohol weihrauch und myrrhe
um sich ordentlich weg zu knallen
aber alkohol ist im familien- rahmen
höchst riskant warum darf ich in der
weihnachtszeit nicht auf eine droge
setzen die gelassen macht
oder eine die mich in meine familie
verliebt macht antwort weil drogen
politik in deutschland von alkoholikern
gemacht wird machen wir einfach mal ein
quiz und vergleichen zwei drogen stoff
ist bewusstseins verändert hat 1,8
millionen teilnehmer in deutschland und
verursacht 74.000 tote jährlich stoff
des bewusstseins verändert hat 300.000
süchtige und null tote jährlich zu
verantworten
frage welcher stoff ist in deutschland
erlaubt antwort der an dem man sterben
kann
das ist so irrational ich nehme allein
schon aus protest gegen wieso
unvernünftige drogenpolitik drogen
vernünftiger wäre es natürlich überhaupt
keine drogen zu nehmen aber der mensch
ist nicht vernünftig erfährt müde auto
popelt unterricht am finger mit dem er
sich eben noch im intimbereich gekratzt
hat in allen zeiten und in allen
kulturen haben menschen drogen genommen
es ist offenbar ein menschliches
bedürfnis sich oben das licht
auszuknipsen
und es bringt nichts dinge zu verbieten
die sich nicht verbieten lassen
die frage soll es drogenhandel überhaupt
geben ist also falsch gestellt sie
sollte er heißen wer soll den
drogenhandel bestimmen und da gibt es
nur zwei möglichkeiten entweder die
kriminellen oder der staat gucken wir
uns mal an wer von einer legalisierung
profitieren würde
es wäre grob gesehen diese institution
zum einen die wirtschaft weil
drogenverkauf arbeitsplätze schafft
solche überhaupt noch weiter
argumentieren arbeitsplätze reichen doch
als argument immer justiz und polizei
würden profitieren weil sie sich um
wichtigere dinge kümmern können
konsumenten würden profitieren weil sie
keine verunreinigten drogen mehr nehmen
müssen der staat würde profitieren durch
steuereinnahmen mehr geldgeil und wer
profitiert von einem weiter so
die kriminellen
ja ok dann lasst uns einfach
weitermachen wie bisher
weitere argumente der legalisierung
gegner veränderung verwirrt mich das
haben wir noch nie so gemacht
man sollte nichts verharmlosen sucht es
eine psychische krankheit und drogen
sind gefährlich aber drogen politik ist
viel effektiver wenn man drogen nicht
mehr zu jeder zeit an jedem kiosk kaufen
kann wenn aufklärung beim arzt und in
der schule stattfindet und wenn über
eine drogen steuer der preis so
gestaltet wird dass der schwarzmarkt
chancenlos bleibt aber solange ich mich
auch an weihnachten nicht auf eine
vernünftige drogen politik verlassen
kann muss ich wo alkohol trinken und
meiner verfügten familie besoffen meine
meinung